[Music]
[Applause]
on October 31st 1999 Halloween here in
the States
my family moved to Los Angeles from a
small flat in England they were at that
time just my parents my brother my
sister a year in three days later I was
born I don't think it was immediately
obvious I was a little different but
round I was for my lack of attention
became more apparent
I wasn't replying new people I just
seemed to ignore them I got my mom so
worried I was partially deaf that she
spent $400 on a fancy hearing test I
passed it with flying colors and I've
never heard the end of it my inability
to focus on anything for any length of
time my forgetfulness I'm a complete
lack of organization is something no a
short of legendary I always lost pencils
never turn in assignments even when I
did them always lift jackets at school
which plane times we've never seen again
I couldn't sit still and if I did sit
still I was talking I talked so much
that even when I wasn't talking my
teachers still told me to be quiet
because it's just soon that was my third
grade teacher put me in my very own
corner of the classroom away from
everything else to try and stop me from
talking what actually happened is I just
shouted across the classroom I was a
nightmare and this whole time I always
had so many miss comments always more
than anyone else fourth grade was a
turning point my mother's been working
to become a teacher and through this she
worked with kids who in the diagnosed
with ADHD and she started to realize
that these kids seemed really familiar
their problems were the same as my
problems by April of 4th grade I've been
to a therapist I've been diagnosed with
ADHD which in a nutshell there's three
things
impulsive 'ti hyperactivity and
inattention impulsivity yeah that's why
I was just always blurting out
whatever's on my mind and talking
aggress hyperactivity I was always
fidgeting much the annoyance of well
everyone around me inattention though is
a bad way to
describe it actually my brain just moves
from one thing to the next very rapidly
until something really catches my
attention and I get kind of sucked in I
might have like a short-lived obsession
about it this is what's responsible my
forgetfulness I can remember things fine
just only when I pay attention that just
doesn't happen often it's also
responsible for many of my life
experiences I've tried all the sports
even baseball which was a terrible idea
you never stick a kid with ADHD on a
field waiting I tried robotics I tried a
few instruments and all of those were a
massive failure
I tried cartooning which I actually got
pretty good at but then I want to learn
how to paint never did and not my
interest is gone I tried to teach myself
computer programming that got boring by
the end of the day the point is I was
always moving from one thing to the next
to treat these symptoms and save my
parents reputation of being able to
raise a child I was given medication
it's probably the single most impactful
event in my entire life in the beginning
it was wonderful it was the fifth grade
I was a model student I not only
finished my work I did it quickly then
help my friends finish their work we're
all done and horsing around while
everyone else is still going the best
part about it was that the third grade
teacher who sat me in a corner was the
fifth grade teacher I can't imagine how
Confucius
this continued in the 6th grade I stayed
organized to stay on top my work got
perfect grades and everything was
wonderful but going into the seventh
grade the dosage of the medication I
took was raised because thought I needed
to cope with the increasing pressure in
middle school this is ironic considering
that in middle school the real pressures
from your peers something that for me
the higher dosage actually damaged all
of a sudden I didn't socialize with
people I became distant I consider ADHD
a part of my personality I mean how can
I not have alluded to my entire life
the high dosage took that away from me
worst of all I couldn't eat was on the
medication I was a pretty skinny kid and
you know my mom kept trying to get me to
eat and every day she'd pack these
lunches and every day they'd end up in
the trash well I told her that when I
was on the medication the food just
seemed totally unappealing the answer
was summed up is this you're just gonna
have to suck it up there wasn't much
else that could be said in response to
all of this I started taking the
medication on and off and well it was
pretty obvious to give you an idea back
in LA there's an ice hockey team the Los
Angeles Kings so I went to one of these
games and I got pretty pumped up every
time anything happened I'd be up and
jumping and cheering the dance camp came
on and to make sure I got on it
I took my shirt off and waived it bought
my head you bet I got on that camera the
next time I went to a Kings game I took
medication right before to focus on some
homework when I went I didn't dance
I barely stood up when the Kings scored
the people I went with were disappointed
because they wanted to see me with the
kind of energy I had before with the
medication I couldn't bring myself to do
any of that those things felt immature
and beneath me teachers would call this
perfect behavior i sat down and I shut
up and I didn't bother anybody this is
an important conflict many kids with
ADHD face
you can either get better grades easier
and lose part of yourself or you can be
who you are and be crucified for it in
the gradebook and for people who find
your normal behavior irritating once I
stopped taking the medication entirely
I got crucified my grades just dropped
people were getting annoyed by me my
friends and family who knew about my
disorder tried to joke about it I guess
they were trying to give me something to
blame it on but really it was degrading
I'd rather take the blame for my
mistakes myself lost some disorder
otherwise it just comes a way of putting
me down like I can't do these things
anyway because I'm not normal this is
only the eighth grade but already life
seemed a lot different then from sixth
grade and I started to wonder if I
really was smart or the medication just
put up an illusion my ego or shattered
and I was just angry and I was bitter
more myself than anything else I didn't
believe myself anymore that I could do
any of the things I used to think I
could and I came in a freshman year of
high school not somebody who's ready to
take on the new challenge I was beaten
before I walk through the door for me it
all goes back to that raising medication
now don't get me wrong
compared to a few other people we've
taken the medication
I had it easy even though most people
who take the medication are perfectly
fine some kids suffer from withdrawal
and summer vacation comes like bad
withdrawal they have the shakes I know a
kid who stayed awake for two days after
taking the medication I've heard of a
kid saw my mom me from working at
schools who'd suicidal thoughts after
taking the medication for the first time
that shouldn't be happening people with
ADHD have a lot to learn about
themselves in order to deal in the
disorder and that's a long process right
now from what I've seen the only
solution people give that works is
medication and if that doesn't work you
kind of just have to work things out for
yourself and sure I get it most people
are fine with the medication they don't
have side effects in too
their lives and enables them to do they
need to get done that isn't the case for
everyone though and the stress and the
pressure and the frustration that common
ADHD for not only the person with the
disorder but the people around them
that's tough it's no coincidence that
when researchers in Sweden shed the
country's national database and checked
suicide rates among people with ADHD and
those without people with ADHD were 10
times more likely to commit suicide 0.2
percent compared to 0.02 percent 1.3
percent of the people without ADHD
attempted suicide for the people with
ADHD that number is 9 point 4 percent
nearly one in 10 family of people with
ADHD risk as well
compared with again 0.02 percent for the
general population parents had a suicide
rate was 0.7 percent siblings had the
same rate of people with ADHD with 0.2%
with statistics like that floating
around
how can medication be good enough for
the entire ADHD population obviously
despite the plenty of people working
fine with the medication there's still a
huge issue for the people you don't have
that luxury and the medication for
whatever reason just isn't the thing
that can help them people who see the
stress they put on their loved ones
every time they mess up and they can't
seem to stop messing up and you'd be
surprised at just how many there are
it's estimated that here in the US four
percent of the adult population has ADHD
for children that number according to
the CDC is 11 percent that's just the
numbers for the US and we're already
looking at millions of people that's
people in this room battling this
battling the stress it causes them
people like me so here's how I dealt
with it
the only way I was going to live with
ADHD and still be happy
it was to beat it I needed to prove that
ADHD wasn't something that was going to
hold me back
so sophomore year after freshman however
I really just let myself down I wanted
to prove not only to others but myself
that I was smart that I could get the
grades I wanted that I could get
involved and still find the time to do
my homework so I got the grades I wanted
and I got involved too I joined the Red
Cross and volunteering for that but one
of most fulfilling things I've ever done
I found ways to do things that work for
me I'm as much as I need to be no more
no less
it's also important for me to find
patterns in classes that even when I
miss out on the things I still always
have a general idea of what's going on
it's very important for me to have
friends and classes so that when my
attention span and it ever really fails
me for classes I don't have an undying
passion for I can still always ask what
directions were just said or what the
homework was all of these things take
work but it's worth it because it
enables me to do what I want to do
really it's about compromising with it
this has allowed me to get off the
medication something which isn't too
common for an ADHD success story now I
can go to school and the me that's there
is the real me I irritate teachers I
struggle do my work and I'm happier I'm
relying on myself no medication no
teachers hovering over me it's possible
whether the medication works for them or
not people with ADHD need to find what
works for them get the support they need
and keep building up self-reliance ADHD
isn't a battle that will ever be totally
won but with a little bit of
understanding we can help millions thank
you
[Applause]